[Music]
with global event 2 now in full swing
has become very apparent that a lot of
people were just not very prepared for
the new close combat modifiers most of
the match made missions have played last
night were far more difficult than they
should have been with modifiers like
crucial and major assault having a
downed agent or two can quickly cause
the whole team to wipe and for this
reason I was actually finding more
success in running missions solo with
the right build this event is actually a
hell of a lot of fun but you really need
to understand the event modifiers when
selecting the right pieces a couple of
weeks ago I released a video on what we
know about the global event assaults in
summary assault is all about close range
but not just that you'll do considerably
more damage at close range but that
you'll also take more damage when at
longer range from the NPC's so from this
we can take away a couple of things that
should be applied to your global event
build 1 we need weapons that excel at
close range and 2 we need to position
ourselves up close to the NPCs this is
where I see a lot of players falling
short
thanks to the main modifier of increased
close combat damage no one really has to
worry about the damage they're doing any
weapon will work up close so for now
let's remove that from the equation the
NPC extended range damage multiplier is
causing a lot of players to be to tempt
before they can even react but don't
jump straight into throwing extra points
into stamina as I've mentioned another
video stamina is a horrifically
inefficient step to focus on in 1.7
instead you should be looking at the
skills we have at our disposal and the
one that sticks out straight away is the
ballistic shield this will allow you to
tank a lot of those shots while you move
within range naturally to take full
advantage of the shield you want to
equip the d3 if in cease it but you
can't stop there with the threat
increase you'll be bringing all of the
enemy fire down on you so you'll need to
have constant flow of healing this is
where health on kill becomes an equally
important part of the build and as a
side note this will also help win
completing the complete without using
medical skills commendations as with all
of my build videos we'll be trying to
keep this as clear and concise as
possible
I'll never state that you need to match
everything I've added to the build and
instead the idea is for you to use this
as a starting point or a template for
your own build change things up and
personalize it for your style of play
this build consists of three piece d3
FNC one piece tactician one piece nomad
and the ninja bike messenger bag the
idea is to be able to tank the majority
of the damage with your ballistic shield
while constantly healing due to your
high dps health on kill setup you may
need to tweak the build slightly
depending on the content you're facing
but generally cover isn't required all
gear pieces have been rolled into
firearms and all major attributes into
skill taste or health on kill in the
first instance or skill power all mods
should be electronics with skill haste
as the attribute applying the above
should leave you with around 7k +
firearms 4k + electronics 50% skill
haste and 25% health on kill the
equipped skills are a ballistic shield
and overdose depending on the difficulty
of the enemies you're facing you may
want to change out overdose for booster
shot most of the time the health on kill
alone is enough to keep you topped up
the three talents old caller must are
critical so combat medic and on the move
combat medic is particularly important
as this will also heal your ballistic
shield when using a mid kit the last
talent one has none is optional you'll
spend a lot of time reloading with this
build so this talent will make your mags
feel like they last a little longer
between reloads it may actually be worth
losing some of the skill haste in order
to roll reload speed onto the holster
the primary weapon I'm using is the mp5
ST with the talents competent brutal and
responsive these talents work quite
nicely with the mp5 and will boost your
damage even further the secondary weapon
almost doesn't need to be looked at I
was using a second SMG with different
talents but it's a bit clunky changing
weapons with the shield er so I found I
never really used it in this example I'm
using the first wave m1 a with cool
headed and brutal but this was really
just to give me some range of the
situation called for it at the end of
this video I've included a cheat sheet
or a quick reference guide that sums up
this build and everything I've covered
check it out and see what you think I'll
leave you with a little bit of gameplay
now but if you'd like to see more of
this type of content subscribe to the
channel and leave a comment below thanks
[Music]
[Music]
morning agent of protein is down
requires assistance
you
[Music]